[Music]
this quaint ski town in Bulgaria checked
all the
boxes affordable rent cheap food great
hiking and fast Wi-Fi when I first told
my friends I'm going to open a coworking
space in this small Bulgarian Mountain
Resort most of them thought I'm totally
crazy that was 7 years ago today bonso
has become a hot spot for digital
Nomads hundreds of remote workers
descend On This Town 2 hours south of
Sophia largely because of this man
Matias
seitler recently I saw someone posting
about emerging Nomad destinations and I
messaged him and I said hey you forgot
banso and he was like banso is not
emerging the digital Nomads here are
from different countries and cultures
they they do different jobs and speak
different
languages but they all share something
in common each is on a personal Journey
searching for meaning connection and
sometimes
[Music]
likes how I structure my n my journey is
that I try to go to all the most popular
digital Nomad destinations around the
world a year and a half ago Ariel Fu
left her 9-to-5 job in finance to travel
full-time she now runs a website called
work anywhere
go I help digal Nomads live on budget
and Inspire other aspiring Nomads to
learn about the lifestyle and how to
achieve location Independence she's
staying at this popular co- living space
for 3 months I really like it here I'm
paying
€230 which is equivalent to about like
350 to Canadian dollars but it has
everything I need her apartment in
Toronto was more than four times that
price and it never quite felt like
home I'm originally from China I've uh
moved to Canada for school and I feel
like I just didn't feel like a strong
sense of community in
Toronto but in this remote Bulgarian
town she finds
it I think a lot of our members come for
the
but they also come for the
community originally from Munich Germany
Matias was a digital Nomad before the
term was even part of the
vernacular after a few years he started
looking for a place to settle down and
then a friend of mine told me about
Bulgaria it has a Mediterranean climate
it has a lot of mountains and it has
only 10% income tax and then of course I
saw 10% income tax is something that I
would like to enjoy in the winter bonco
is one of the the top ski destinations
in the
balons but in the off seon the town home
to about 10,000 bulgarians typically
quiets down until recently hey guys
welcome
to Matias organizes the world's largest
digital Nomad Festival here in the
summer you can really feel that the
whole town became way more
International bonco is the first of many
stops around the world for Finch
burgling I want to go to Slovakia then
to Hungary um Austria to Republic Poland
Finch is a songwriter and music producer
6 months ago he left his home in Tel
Aviv after seeing social media posts of
people traveling the globe and sharing
tips on how he could do it too I
realized you don't have to be rich if
you want to see the world like all you
need is a laptop and you can keep
walking this whole idea which was seen
as quite Niche before the
pandemic very quickly came into the
mainstream Dave Cook is an
anthropologist at University College
London he's studied digital Nomads since
2015 that was a time when social media
was already mainstream here's five
remote jobs you can start doing today to
become a digital Nomad we then have had
Instagram and influencers and that
played a big role in the growth and
promotion of of the lifestyle but Behind
These carefully curated posts are a lot
of unknowns it was really scary for me
just to go to another place and I don't
know if I'm going to know
anyone but then I realized that in um
banso you have a
community while co-working banso was the
first there are now nine co-working
spaces in this small town and it is
really interesting that often times you
have people that that travel thousands
of miles around the world rejecting the
office and then they go to a co-working
space which is effectively a rebranded
office the movement is facing backlash
in popular destinations like Lisbon
Barcelona and Mexico City where locals
say remote workers are straining housing
markets a lot of the Heat and criticism
is arising in places that already have a
lot of tourist gentrification issues but
in bonco there's no sign of this tension
yet and Matias is already onto his next
big
Venture welcome to coring
Cal this Grand resort was built 30 Years
Ago by the Socialist Bulgarian
[Music]
government then it was sold off to a
hotel operator and the last 5 years it
has been unused
his plan is to transform this 177,000
squ met building into a massive co-
living space for digital
Nomads there will be meeting rooms there
will be co-working areas there will be a
restaurant we will have about up to 250
people living in this building directly
in nature which means there's many
opportunities to connect with each
other the building may be in disarray
now but Matias sees its
potential just like 7 years
ago when he arrived in
bonow the idea is create a space where
people can find a sense of belonging and
they will come as long as there's fast
Wi-Fi are you happier now than you were
in Toronto I think definitely
yes I might stop being Nomad in a few
month tomorrow I don't
know I just want to find a source of
[Music]
happiness